(upbeat string music)
(speaking in a foreign language)
- [Narrator] We all know that everything
tastes better deep-fried.
But what if I told you that in Thailand,
the same goes for flowers?
Eating flowers goes back generations
to when other foods were scarce
and today, can be found
in both luxury restaurants
and street vendors alike.
One such island where you can find
these crispy beauties is Koh
Kret, just outside Bangkok.
(speaking in a foreign language)
Boonrod has been selling
fried flowers in Koh
Kret for over 10 years.
The flowers she sells are harvested
from her very own garden as
well as those of her neighbor's.
And her morning starts early.
(speaking in a foreign language)
Some of the flowers you can find
in Boonrod's shop are butterfly pea,
bougainvillea and Ixora.
(speaking in a foreign language)
At 73 years old, Boonrod
is the oldest vendor
selling fried flowers on the island.
But she isn't protective
of her original recipe
for the travelers who come to Koh Kret.
(speaking in a foreign language)
And also because Boonrod knows
her fried flowers are
just plain delicious.
(speaking in a foreign language)
You can bet that we'll be back for more.
(upbeat string music)